All right people.
We are live on the youtube
and the Facebook and I am
with a bestselling author,
a radio host,
and a man who wants beat me senseless
in front of millions of people.
Larry elder, who I'll come back to
the Ruben report to this as well.
This will be around three. How are you?
This is, so we're at to rocky through C,
but if it was rocky, no, no, it's
like Muhammad Ali and Frazier Ali.
You lost the first one. Frazier. Ali
lost the first one. One the second one,
and then they had the,
had the big third one thrown in the
middle of this is Thrilla in Manila? Yes.
Thrilla in Manila.
See,
I wish this was more like rocky
because in the original rocky they,
it was to a standstill rocky
one, right? Nobody wins.
Rocky two rocky finally wins.
And then three,
well that at that point you're retired.
I think Ruben,
the only question is which one of us has
Ali? Which one? It is this appraiser.
We shall find out my friend. All
right. So, uh, you just sat down here,
but we've already talked
about comic books,
about basketball and we
black panther about racism,
about a Trump. Uh, I think we
covered everything by. All right,
well let's do a little bit of
in for the people. So I first,
I just want to jump back to that original
moment because I said it to you last
time you were here,
which was about a year ago and when that,
that moment where you really beat
me senseless about systemic racism,
that was about two years ago already,
if, if not more at this point.
And so many people,
I was just in London two days ago and I
did a Q and a and people were asking me
about it. I mean that thing really has,
there are many versions of it on Youtube.
It's just caught fire. And as I
said to you last time, it was Sorta,
I view it as my best moment
as, and my worst. It was my
worst because I came to a,
an intellectual fight without the proper
equipment and it was my best because we
left it in. And let it be. And
it was a learning moment for me.
And then for everyone else,
well,
you had a lot of class for leading it
and a lot of people would've would've
taken it out and no one would have
known it happened. And secondly,
the older one gets,
the more difficult it is for one
to kind of change one's beliefs.
And for you to do it at
your age to rethink your
assumptions. I takes a lot of,
a lot of guts.
A lot of people don't want to do that.
And I appreciate pretty depressing
thing, don't you think? I agree with you.
Most people don't want to do it.
I think we've fostered here something
that is allowing people to do it,
but most people don't want to do
that. You know? And it's funny,
we're in an atmosphere
where just a moment ago,
I'm driving in listening to talk radio
and I think it's CNN or MSNBC and they're
going on and on about how Trump has now
made lying, uh, the currency of the day.
And no one tells the truth anymore.
Facts don't matter.
And they're talking about the
kinds of lying that Trump does,
where he talks about the crowd size and
how much money he has and stuff like
that. The lies of the left are huge
lines and the damage the country,
the lie that racism remains a major
problem in America. It's a lie,
the lie that women make 77 cents on the
dollar for doing the same thing that men
do it, it's a lie, the lie that rich
get richer, the poor get poorer.
These are lies and these are big lies
that drive the left and drive votes.
These are the kinds of things that matter.
So when you sit across from a guy like me,
and the first time we did it when I
really still felt I was part of the,
I was trying to reform the
left. Realistically, I'm not
part of the left anymore,
you know,
and again,
the left right thing is we talk about
all the time doesn't even have that much
meaning anymore. It's
really about Authoritarians,
Libertarians and all that. Um,
but for all the years
that you've been doing,
staking out conservative positions for
how many years publicly and want to drive
25 years, was there a more
sensible left at the time?
Was there a guy you could sit across from
that you disagreed with intellectually,
but felt that it was, it was
forthright, it was honest.
You just disagreed with the
methodology and the results. Sure.
There were lots of people
that I felt that way with.
And William Buckley had a
very good friend, uh, uh,
John Kenneth Galbraith who
was a left wing economist.
They disagreed about everything. They
were good friends. I believe it or not,
Antonin Scalia, his best friend on the
Supreme Court, Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
What it requires,
if somebody to recognize that if I have
a position that's different from yours,
it doesn't mean that I'm a bad guy.
It doesn't mean that I'm evil.
It means that I see the world differently.
It takes a certain kind of
maturity to do that. Unfortunately,
we've gotten to the place now where if
you don't believe that racism is a major
problem in America, uh, if you're black,
you're a sellout. If you're white,
you're a racist. If you say something
negative about the Black Panther,
which I just did, I got hammered,
got some guy told me that, well,
it's because as a black person and a
black director and a black hero and
therefore you don't like it. I mean, the,
the star is guy named Chadwick Bozeman.
And I was fortunate enough to be
invited to see the premiere of 42.
He was brilliant. I saw the movie three
or four times. I like him so much.
I saw him in, um, uh, a movie
about Thurgood Marshall,
which was a very good movie,
probably not commercially, uh, uh,
successful, but it was a very good movie.
And I saw him play in the movie with the,
we play James Brown. He was very good.
The movie wasn't that good, but he was
good. Yeah. So he's an intriguing actor.
Again, I don't go to see a movie to,
to not be happy to waste my time. Yeah.
And you're a comic book guy. I mean
we were talking about comic books is,
cause I've got a whole bunch in the
green room here and you were immediately
going on.
I've got all this stuff you love.
So it's not like you're walking
into that thing to hate it. Right.
And so the criticism is just bizarre.
I mean, what do you think I am?
What do you think I do?
I get from the morning hate myself,
Dow to my eyeballs out quite a claw, my
skin color off. I mean that's just, and,
and, and, and they, I feel
sorry for people like that.
People have often asked me,
does it make you mad? It
doesn't. I feel sorry for you.
If you are so trained,
so indoctrinated to be that's rabid
against somebody who just has a different
point of view. There's a problem
with you, not with me, you know?
Well on that note,
I owe you a public thanks.
Not just because you beat me
senseless and helped me get here.
But also because everyone knows about
the interview I did with Thomas Soul and
we had been working on it for about
three years. You sent him a note,
I don't know if that was what
pushed him over the edge,
but I think it was one of the really,
one of the big things that I've been
able to do here to bring some of those
ideas back. And that's what you've
been doing for a long time. He's like,
he's like JD Salinger. It's hard. It's
hard. It's hard. It's hard to get him.
We have to get 'em out once you
get him. He's, he's amazing. Yeah.
And I met him because I
was on cspan at the time.
I had a four hour live radio show and
cspan broadcast of the entire show and I
get a letter from Thomas Soul.
It was like getting a letter
from Elvis and it said, um,
my wife and I watched your entire show.
Your, you were great. Uh, you, you, uh,
you laid out all the arguments,
very well done.
And I wrote him back and we got
together several times since then.
We've become very good friends.
Yeah.
So I sense a massive shift
happening in politics right now.
And clearly the center of it right at
the moment is with the black community.
I don't even like using phrases like
that because I don't like that collective
thing.
But sometimes you gotta you gotta talk
about things in a way that allow most
people to understand
them. So, uh, you know,
what is it about two and a half weeks
ago or so? Kanye west seven words.
I love the way Candace
Owens thinks. Wow. Yeah.
Now do you think that is as big of a game?
Yeah,
I think it is a game changer. Yeah. Um,
in the sense that Kanye West has
28 million Twitter followers,
I don't know how many Instagram,
I don't know how many Facebook
would you add them all together?
It's a boatload of people.
He has more influence on the
way black people think. Uh,
then Clarence Thomas, uh,
Thomas Soul, Walter Williams,
Larry elder put together unfortunately.
Uh,
and for him to say that and to begin
the process of making it okay for black
people to rethink their assumption, they
can okay to say, I'm not a democrat.
That's a huge thing.
95% of black voters voted for Obama.
Uh, Trump did a little bit better,
but not a whole lot better.
If the Democrats lose 10,
15, 20% of that black vote,
they are toast at the national level,
which is why people like me have to be
vilified. People like Candace Collins are,
are now direct threats to the
domination of the Democratic Party.
People like Kanye West, they've got to
be put down. They've got to be demeaned.
You can't just say he's got
a different point of view.
You've got to say something
that's fundamentally,
fundamentally wrong with them.
Otherwise, how are you get 95% of people
to vote and see the world one way?
And you have to show them, prove to
them, uh, convinced them that they,
that these guys are against you, that, uh,
that you're evicted crat
and these are victimizers.
And that's what the left
has done so successfully.
And so when you saw the reaction to him,
now again, I, we briefly discussed this,
but I don't think either one of us know
what his political beliefs are. Reviewed.
Even if he has, he knows
what they are, but just,
just not to a hate republicans.
Not to hate Trump for that is a
big deal. Thank you know, we're,
we're in Hollywood. You and
I are, is there an a list
our doing it here. I have no,
is there an alias actor or an alias
actress in his or her twenties or thirties
who've come out and said, I love Trump.
None. Nobody. You get some older ones.
Maybe they've already established,
you've said a few things,
but is there somebody right now who's hot,
uh,
on the brink of stardom
or just just in stardom,
who's come out in favor of Trump? No,
Trump just say basic conservative. Yeah,
because it would be
damaging to their career.
It's not possible to 100% of them
think the same way. I don't think so.
There's gotta be a few, but when they
come out and say something, of course not.
[inaudible] how'd you get to walk of fame?
A star?
[inaudible] you pay off for that. Then
when someone asked me that report is that,
how did that happen?
I said,
well this is what happens when you make
a substantial donation to the Clinton
Foundation. Um, I have no idea.
I know that I'm nominated all the time
because I would get some sort of inquiry
from people telling me that you've been
nominated and nothing ever happened.
So I didn't think anything would
happen. Low and behold, who know? Yeah.
When you think of the odd
levels of racism in this town,
like just the way they do things,
like just a couple of weeks ago
when they boot Cosby out of the, uh,
whatever it is, the television
and Kevin Arts along along that,
so then they do Roman
plants in the same day,
but it was so obvious that it was like,
oh, we got to take care of Cosby now,
but we don't want to make it seem
like we're just booting the black guy.
So where is the white guy we
can get rid of? And you know,
I don't think anything to
do with black or white.
I think they realize the hypocrisy.
I think they realized if we're,
if we're kicking out bill costs because
of allegations of rape and here's a guy
who pled guilty to rape a teenager.
Yeah.
And we're celebrating him.
We have a problem here.
So costly caused them to have to be
consistent. If nothing to do with,
with plants. He's race or Carthy is
race. He had to deal with, with the,
with the bizarre concept of somebody
being booted out because he was accused of
rape and somebody who was charged with
it and pled guilty to it. He's okay.
I think in their own
warped worldview though,
if Cosby had been white and they
felt they had to get rid of him,
they wouldn't have felt that they needed
to get rid of another white guy made.
Maybe I get it. I believe it's possible,
but they've caused us to think this way.
Right. That's what I'm saying. I'm
just trying to get in their minds.
I'm not trying to get in and
get in our minds. Um, but okay.
I want to get back to what you just said
about the reaction to Kanye because the
reaction to me, it seemed, it
wasn't just that people were like,
he's wrong cause he likes
Trump because you know,
lists for things that are
sensible. It was, you know,
Candice is far right.
Kanye is on opioids.
10 other smear pieces on both
of them, et Cetera, et cetera.
And I think you're probably
very aware of why that is.
And you kind of hinted at it, but can
you explain why it's always so overboard?
Well, again, anybody who threatens
their 95% monolithic black vote,
uh, is an enemy. Uh, they've gotta be
dealt with. They've got to be put down.
And black people have been indoctrinated
to believe that racism is this massive,
massive problem in the world,
when in fact it isn't a massive,
massive problem in America,
when in fact it isn't. Yeah,
I was on CNN the last time I was
on the sh the dot lemon show.
I reminded them of a 1997 pole that
CNM and Time magazine did wear black
teenagers and white teenagers were asked,
is, is racism major problem in America?
I think you and I might've talked
about this. Yeah. And more, more um,
white teams and black teams said racing.
It was a major problem in America.
And then when the poll ask,
is racism a big problem,
a small problem or no problem,
and your own daily lives,
90% of the black teens set a small problem
or no problem. In my own daily lives.
That was in 1997. Now, that was before
Obama and before Obama got reelected.
You're telling me now things are
worse now than they were back then.
Yet our so called black leadership,
people like Keith Ellison,
people like Louis Farrakhan, people like
Jesse Jackson, people like Sharpton, the,
the, uh, the, the, the, the
neighbors over on MSNBC and CNN.
If you contracted on those guys,
you'd be afraid to leave
your house if you were black.
So what do you think is actually
going on in the minds of these guys?
I know you're not a mind reader,
but like is it,
is it truly bad intentions
or is it moral confusion,
political confused hard.
It's hard. It's hard to say.
I think some of it is cynical. Some of it
is, uh, is bs. Uh, recently for example,
I just saw that a chapter had of an in
and AACP chapter in South Carolina wrote
a big Facebook post about being pulled
over and the officer asked him about
drugs and asking him about, um, uh,
why are you having such a fancy car?
And he wanted a big pace Facebook
posts about it. Unfortunately,
the officer recorded everything and it
turned out everything the Guy Dad was
alive. This is the chapter head of the
Naacp in that town in South Carolina.
Now if racism so bad that you
have to make up stuff, man, man,
that shows you the,
the,
the call that victim hood has right now
for whatever. Remember the young lady,
the actors from the movie Django here
in Santa Monica. Uh, and she was, um,
apparently having sex with
her boyfriend in her car.
Somebody called nine one one and she
choose the officer's of, of, of a,
of asking all sorts of things
about her, uh, about her race.
And she didn't realize she
had been recorded. Turns
out she with wrong. And uh,
a judge made her write a letter
of apology. I mean really it,
so what do you do?
What do you do?
I was at University of New Hampshire
two weeks ago and they were a bunch of
protesters there. Black lives
matter, sent a bunch of people.
And I kept saying that I'm
for everyone having, you know,
equal respect under the law and you
can't say all lives matter. That's races.
Racist even said black lives matter.
Cause I was,
I did everything I could to make it
clear that I want us all to be treated
equally with dignity, with, I mean you,
but you know what it's like when
you get some of these protesters,
the ones that are not,
not a,
not an average protester who may
want to listen a little bit and then,
and then ask a question, right? When
you get the ones that are just there to,
to borate and scream and the rest. So
one of the, one of the protesters are,
there were a couple at one point
who were saying, uh, you know,
somebody like we could be shot when we
get out of here, all this hate speech,
all of this stuff.
And I realized,
even though I kept saying what I believe
to be true and what I believe to be
right, there was almost
nothing I could do. Right.
So what do you do for those people?
Because I think the masses
are shifting a little bit,
but what do you do for that?
You're not going to win every argument.
You really can't.
And if somebody is invested with the
idea that the man is holding me back,
that officers pulled me
over because of my race.
There's not a whole lot you can do about
it. You can point to studies. I mean,
it's been studied. They're not big on
studies. And under Obama in 20 2013,
I think it was the uh,
national institutes of justice,
which is the research arm of the DOJ,
did a study on it called
race and traffic stops.
Turned out 75% of the black
motorist who were stopped, said,
I got stopped for legitimate reasons.
It turned out that you named
a traffic offense. Speeding,
driving went out, uh, uh,
your, your lights on driving
without a seatbelt on, uh,
driving without proper registration.
You name the offense,
a black motorist with work with
more likely to come to commit it.
And the Nij report said,
yes,
blacks are stopped more often than whites
are with the reasons have to do with
differences in offending.
End of quote came out under Obama quietly,
nobody talked about it.
How much of this then is just a failure
of what the Republicans have done?
I get you on all of the things that the
Democrats and the left had sold that are
lies.
I get the way they,
they manipulate all these
different minority communities,
but it seems to me because there
is a resurgence now, right?
Like the first thing I said
to Thomas Soul are, yeah,
are you excited that you know
you're having this resurgence?
He kind of looked at me like, well, you
know, I've been doing this for 50 years.
Can sort of,
or that people now share the clip of us
endlessly and Candice and Connie and all
of this. Um, it, this
does seem to become a Mac,
but some of this has to be on
the Republicans too, right?
That, that it got so bad.
Well, yeah, I mean the Republicans
have done a bad job in um,
and marketing their brand. And most
people don't even know that, uh,
the Democrats oppose the 13th, 14th,
15th Amendment sometimes. Unanimously.
Most people don't know that
as a percentage of the party,
more Republicans voted for the passage
of the Civil Rights Act and the Senate
and in the house then did Democrats.
And there's this myth that, um, uh,
what happened is it was this big switch
in the 60s when all the racists, uh, uh,
from the south left the Democratic Party
and joined a public and party when in
fact,
if you look at all of the Democrats who
voted against the civil rights act in
the house, and the Democrats have
all of them only to switched parties,
it became Republicans. Um, the first, uh,
Republican senator from Tennessee since
reconstruction was a guy named Howard
Baker, who was a guy who was in
favor of integration. So it's,
it's a big lie and Republicans have done
a poor job, uh, in and telling the truth.
The other thing is Republicans,
uh,
are gentle when they're called racists.
They often just don't say anything or
ignore it and hope the moment goes away.
Recently, Mike Kelly from Pennsylvania,
a Republican member of the house,
squared off with Maxine waters.
It was his bogus report that purported
to show that a auto dealers, uh,
Jack over black people by charging
them more interest rates to get loans,
when in fact, all of these
things are done by algorithms.
There's no nothing to do with race at all.
And my Kelly happened to be
in the car business. Well,
he knew it wasn't true and he challenged
her and he said something to the effect
of we Republicans have an obligation to
when we are confronted with nonsense to
call it and we just need, we need to
start calling it. And that's the problem.
People often say to me, Larry, you
can say stuff we can't say. Yeah,
really you are incapable of, of
articulating the words. I just,
your brain cannot put out the
conversation. I just did. Yeah.
And that's the problem when white
people are called racist, um,
why don't you defend yourself? Um, you
know who you are. You know how you feel,
you know what you've done,
you know what your thoughts
are and someone calls you
racist and you'd let it go.
I mean, it's a problem. Yeah. Are you
feeling this glow right now? I mean,
you must be feeling pretty good about
this. Like something has shifted here.
It's gotta. It's gotta feel good. Right,
right. I can, I can sense that. Well,
you saw a poll and it showed a, you
know, I'm big on facts not on feeling.
I'll be right back.
So I was letting you have a feeling you,
the polls show that the support
for Trump doubled among black men.
Incredible rates from 11 to 22% and
less than a week and about a week and it
shows you there was a dyke and
once the dyke broke, it broke.
And the support for blacks in general
has increased, uh, about 50%, uh,
uh,
for Trump over the last few weeks.
All it because Kanye West's Candice Owen
have made it okay for people all around
the country.
They have conversations like you and I
are having right now and these kinds of
conversations are taking place and
Blakley who were saying, wait a second,
Donald Trump wants to build a wall and
do something about illegal immigration in
part because studies have shown there's
a economist named George Boerhaaves,
he'd probably done more work on
the impact of illegal immigration.
Any other economists, there's no question.
He writes that illegal immigration,
unskilled especially, um, post is
competition for jobs for people.
In the inner city and puts downward
pressure on their wages to Donald Trump
wants to,
wants to do something about that.
And studies have shown that when parents
have vouchers, the results are better.
The kids graduate at a higher rate,
their test scores are better.
And the parental satisfaction
is through the roof.
And Donald Trump wants to provide inner
city parents with vouchers and the polls
show that inner city parents want them.
And the Teacher's Union,
which is right in the pocket of the
Democratic Party and vice versa,
does not want you to have those.
But Donald Trump is a bigot.
So people all around the country having
this conversation and the economy has
done well. And under Obama, the
black labor force participation rate,
the percentage of black men looking for
jobs or working a hadn't been that low
since they were keeping stats.
And under Donald Trump,
black unemployment isn't at all time
low in part because he's lower taxes and
stopped turning back. Some of these stupid
regulations that strangle businesses,
uh,
and when business doesn't do well,
the people that suffer the most
are the people at the bottom.
The ones that need a job and don't
have a job and Donald Trump is doing
something about that.
But he's a racist.
Well that's kind of a
difficult argument to make.
His daughter was a converted Jew.
One member of his cabinet is the
formerly respected Ben Carson,
but Donald Trump's a bigot.
Don't forget our are openly gay.
Uh, now ambassador to Germany, right
at Grinnell, right. And a series of,
and don't forget all the mini Haley
and all and all the material you see of
Donald Trump hanging out
with Jesse Jackson and Al
Sharpton back in the day when,
uh, when they thought that
he could benefit them and
now all of a sudden he's a
bigger,
it's outrageous.
And that conversation is being taken
place all over the country. Also, rappers,
as you well know, used to rap about
Trump all the time. No one syllable word,
his word word is named
Ryan did a lot of stuff.
So they used it and they often talked
about aspiring to be like Trump.
Then he ran for president. He became an
sob. How did that happen? Do you think?
He was just the guy that was the only
guy that could have done it, basically.
I think so Hilary was the best funded,
uh, best back candidate ever seen.
Um,
and it took somebody to take on the
media and to cut through CNN and MSNBC
through social media. Also,
Trump snuck up on people.
The media is really angry at
themselves for letting it happen.
I read that he got about $2 billion in
free advertising now. A lot of it was bad.
Yeah.
But the numbers went up whenever they,
whenever they showed him
the numbers went up and,
and as began knocking off
people and knocking all people,
they realized that he was being taken
seriously and then it was too late. Yeah.
You know, it's interesting
you mentioned that, that poll,
that 11 to 22% amongst black male pole,
that thing came out.
I quickly saw it on Twitter and then
I kind of looked around. I was like,
wait a minute. This seems massive. Like
why we shouldn't understate this. Right.
A doubling of support right now. If at
any point it had doubled under Obama,
although it was, you're saying it was
high enough to the point that it probably,
it couldn't have doubled but under right.
Any other situation
with any other minority,
the media would have been going on bananas
and it wasn't, I think as I recall,
respected poll to wasn't Reuters.
Uh, I'm not totally sure,
but by every estimation he was
a legit legit pole. Yeah. Yeah.
So that just shows you where
the media is at with this.
They can't talk about it to talk about
it also then Lynn's energy to it and when
courage more and more people
to rethink their assumptions.
So let's just ignore it. Yeah.
I once asked Thomas Soul,
when you write a column like this,
I forget what column it was.
There was some column I think challenge
challenging the assumption of race based
preferences. And he challenged
some big study and I said,
when you write something like this
and you effectively refute some study,
what happens? He said, usually nothing.
He said they went and they move
on to something else. Yeah,
man, there's the long game here.
It's a long, long game for sure. Um,
so when I've had you on one of
the push backs that I get after,
people always say, well, all right,
well I'll grant him a little stuff.
Like if they're willing to give you a
little something, they'll go, all right,
he made me write, we don't have
laws that are against black people.
So it's not systemic if that's
what you're defining systemic as.
And people seem to have a couple different
definitions of systemic, but they'll,
they'll talk about the history of
inequality and why that needs to be
compensated for now. Now I
suspect you might say, well,
most of those policies that have created
that inequality or because of the
Democrats, but that's the last word
I'm going to put in your mouth. Well,
how do you acknowledge that
argument? Well, all a state can be,
it's just in its own time.
Um, my father wasn't a slave.
Um, my father never met his father, but
uh, I'm sure he wasn't a slave either.
And so the people right now on the face
of the earth have had nothing to do with
historical injustices to black people.
Uh,
and you could take a wand and wave it
over America and remove every Smidgen of
racism from the hearts of White America.
How will that solve the social problem
with that are really facing the black
community?
Primarily the large number of black kids,
they were raised without fathers in
the home. 73% right now, 73% right now,
black kids are raised without fathers.
25% of inner city black kids have a
criminal record, either arrested in jail,
on parole,
or on probation.
50% of the inner city kids are
dropping out of high school.
And those that do graduate often cannot
read, write, and compute at grade level.
What does any of that had to do with
racism? And many of these cities, uh,
and school boards have been
run by Democrats and run by
black people for decades.
So, okay. So if we remove the racism part
of it, but acknowledge those numbers,
your answer would be that we have to,
what then changed the education system?
I mean for me it's the, you got to start.
It all starts in the home recently. Uh,
I was pleased to watch Denzel Washington
being interviewed about his movie. Uh,
Roman j Israel.
Yeah.
Which was about a criminal defense lawyer
and someone put a mic in his face, uh,
and ask Denzel Washington,
what about the large number of,
of blacks who were being warehoused
by the criminal justice system.
And I just knew he was going
to say something about, yeah,
we need to do something about the systemic
racism, blah, blah, blah. He didn't,
he said,
it all starts in the home.
I saw it in my generation and
every generation thereafter. Uh,
if you're raised by the streets,
uh,
then the streets become your father and
the course become your home and the GL
becomes your, your residence as what he
said. Something to that effect. And it was
spot on. I didn't expect
it. Uh, and again,
I think things like that when you add
them all up will cause people to start
rethinking their assumptions.
Yeah.
Are you feeling it like when you're doing
your radio show on you're taking calls
now or it's hard. It's hard to
say because you know, this is a,
I'm often preaching to
the crowd. Yeah. Um,
I like to think that the reason my numbers
are so big is that I'm getting people
that don't normally listen
to a conservative slash
libertarian, a talk show host.
But it's hard to say because the
people call in are motivated,
they're driven to call in. They
don't necessarily represent
the, uh, the entire, um,
population base.
So it's hard to say.
Plus you t you choose calls
because they're entertaining
because the person has
a good point of view, has a good speaking
voice. Uh, it gets to the point quickly.
So there are all sorts of factors that
go into it. So it's not scientific. Yeah,
I like that you just describe yourself
as a conservative slash libertarian cause
I think on the, on the libertarian side of
stuff, I think we're, we're pretty much,
yeah,
as close to lock step as you can get.
What do you see as the differences
between those two positions?
Does it even matter to you?
Well,
the reason I use that is because
people often call me a conservative.
I don't consider myself that I
consider myself to be a libertarian,
a smaller libertarian who
they're registered Republican.
I don't run from the term conservative.
Um, and most of my views are conservative,
but I, but I'm more libertarian than
conservative even mean to you anymore.
What is like the phrase [inaudible]
when I think of a conservative,
think of a fiscal conservative
and a social conservative. Uh,
and on things like same sex marriage,
things like a doctor assisted suicide,
things like, uh, like drugs.
I believe all those things should
be done on a state by state basis.
I'm a federalist though, that way a lot
of conservatives are perfectly okay with,
in my opinion, passing
laws that would, uh,
banned certain behavior that
they don't like. And, and
I'm, I'm not, uh, I'm not, uh,
in that camp.
Okay.
I guess also conservatives
probably,
I remember listening to Ann Coulter,
Ann Coulter was talking
about how she posed the, um,
the idea of legalizing drugs and talked
about the cost to society for that.
Well, a libertarian wouldn't
think that way at all.
That you just accept that. What price to
pay for freedom, basically. Freedom is,
is a, is expensive. Uh, it's, it's,
it's, it's a value in and of itself.
And when you talk about the cost of this,
the cost of that,
what about the cost of freedom? What
about the value of freedom? The value,
the value of being able
to do what you want,
provided you're not hurting somebody else.
So when you said something to the effect
of that were all men of our own time,
do you think all you can be, it's just
in your, oh, you can be adjusted, Justin,
that's even better.
So when you said that if we were to look
back when we had federal laws and that
were, that actually were racist and
Jim Crow laws and things like that,
and then we had the civil rights act
of 1963 or 64, I always forget 64.
Um,
now that stopped it at the federal level.
Would you have been okay if
the states had dealt with that?
Because I get that one a lot now because
people will say rytary and they made
the argument again,
it's probably the biggest question and
the biggest argument that people have
against Libertarians. Yeah. Um, uh,
Barry Goldwater voted against
the civil rights act of 1964.
He became the standard bearer for
the Republican Party and 64, uh,
he later on said he regretted
his vote against the bill.
But at the time he said,
I'm voting against the bill because of
libertarian reasons. He wasn't a racist.
He didn't believe the government should
tell you if you're operating a store,
whether or not somebody could
come in and come out. Um,
and whether or not you are,
should be forced to serve somebody.
And he is not wrong. I know that
freaks a lot of black people out. Uh,
but think about it.
Uh,
the country changed rapidly
and laws can't make you change.
We change and therefore the laws changed
because we changed. Uh, America changed.
Um, and bigotry,
there's zero tolerance for anti black.
White bigotry is zero tolerance
for it in America. My goodness.
Anybody who's out in as
a bigot gets hammered.
Look what happened to Donald Sterling.
He lost his team for crying out loud.
So if some guy somewhere decided he wanted
to open up a bar and no black people
come and sign this as only whites,
he would be socially maligned. Friends
who go there have friends who go there,
uh, would malign the person. When
I lived in Cleveland in the 70s,
there was an area called little Italy
and I was told if you go to little Italy,
you're black, they will spit in your food.
They don't want you there. Everybody,
everybody I know told me that.
So nobody I know went there.
Anybody I know who did go there, if they
told anybody they will socially, uh,
scoring.
And then the 14 years I would living in
Cleveland elite got smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller.
So racism is not financially beneficial.
Um, the reason branch Rickey hire Jackie
Robinson with not to be a civil rights
pioneer, he wanted to beat
the Damn Yankees and he
wanted to fast shortstop, uh,
a first baseman who could do it.
Uh,
and once other teams realize that these
guys were good, they had to get them to,
yeah.
So although I can tell you wouldn't
be for reversing the civil rights act,
you could make an argument in a modern
sense for that all of these things should
just be kicked to the states.
Right? Right. Correct.
Yeah. I'm there on that too,
which I think people are always
attacking libertarians for in,
regarding federal institutions like
schools and things like that, that, that,
that our, that our government, uh, of
course, uh, the 14th amendment applies.
But can you explain why?
Because again,
this is where I think
people just get lost. Well,
the 14th amendment says no state, uh,
Shell, uh, deny anybody equal protection.
So it's gotta be a state actor, uh, a, uh,
a college or university that state,
but a private university should be able
to do what they want even though none of
them can because everybody
accepts federal dollars.
And therefore the government can tell
you what to do. There is one university,
Hillsdale and a few others
that don't take any,
any federal money and therefore they
can admit who they want by whatever
criteria they want. And
that ought to be what, uh,
what should happen in any institution
in the private sector, whether it's a,
a grocery store or, or,
or college or university.
What do you make of just the line of
thinking that we would ever be able to set
a series of laws in place
that would perfect the whole
damn thing because that's
really what this comes down to. They,
they think basically we can just,
we can basically Riedel away your
ability to think really, right.
And then you'll all act like sort of
automatons and behave and no one will be
racist and whatever.
But at the same time,
and we know this because of
silicon valley right now,
no one will be able to come up
with the ingenuity of thought.
No one will have an original premise
or ability to do anything cool anymore.
Right. Um, well that's a problem with the
left. That's why their moral busy body.
So right now,
and I think a Seattle,
they just passed a law that's going
to tax businesses so that, so that uh,
they can build more,
more shelter for homeless people.
The more you encourage
this kind of behavior.
It was just there in Seattle last week.
A lot of homeless people
that are going to get, yeah.
Have you been downtown La recently? Yeah,
up in Seattle, up in, up in San Francisco.
Uh,
these are all places that are all left
wing and they're very generous and they
all feel sorry for the
homeless and therefore they're
making it easier, easier,
easier for homeless people all over
the country to move there and making it
easier and easier for you to be a little
less responsible because you know,
you're going to get a house. There's
somebody who's going to pay for, yeah.
So as a guy that you were born in La,
right? So you were born and raised in La.
First of all, why are we going?
Why, why, why haven't you?
You want to do a little thing on
it and you, it's a, um, first off,
I don't know where I'm going to go with
that. I have to interrupt you or not.
You don't have to. You interrupted
by flow. So, um, first all,
why haven't you run against
Maxine waters already? I mean,
what are you doing for God sakes? Let
me support you. Please. I would lose,
I supported a guy named Ross mowing
against her a few years ago and I've,
this is the only time I ever really
went out and campaign for somebody else.
I mean, I made speeches for
him, a donut, gave money to him,
had him on my radio show a bunch of times,
a Vietnam vet, great guy, white guy.
And he lost,
I want to say 84% to 16%.
I mean, it was just a smashing. Um, she,
she has that district
in her hands. And, um,
I mean she strikes me as actually
dangerous to democracy at a certain level.
When she keeps going up,
we're going to,
we're going to find the
reason to impeach him.
She had who the president is for
sure what he thinks she is dangerous,
but they will tell you who I think the
more dangerous people like Eric Holder
because Eric Holder is taken seriously by
the left. Maxine waters, the caricature,
they have her for the reasons I mentioned
earlier, to keep life people angry,
to stoke up the anger,
but no one takes us seriously when
Eric Holder comes out and says, um,
that the fact that black
boys are disproportionally
expelled from their schools
compare to their population percentage
when he calls that pernicious racism,
when in fact it's because of their
bad behavior that's taken seriously.
When Eric Holder says that the reason
blacks get longer sentences, uh,
compared to white criminal, definitive
committed the same crime, uh,
when the US sentencing commission says
the reason is because judge has taken to
consideration arrest records at
the end of the sentencing process.
And the black criminal
defendant unfortunately has
a bigger restaurant arrest
record than the average white guy, uh,
who gets arrested for the same crime. Uh,
and Eric Holder in a speech referred
to that disparity as pernicious racism,
even though the sentencing commission
said what I just now said. Um,
Eric Holder says that the push for voter
id, which the majority of blacks want,
uh, is pernicious racism.
This guy is taken seriously.
That's the one that really bothers me,
that when they imply that somehow
black people can't get an id, I mean,
you have to have an idea to drive a car,
right?
You have to have an id to go into
a bar, some assault, some of,
some of the events that
Maxine waters puts on.
You have to have an ID to get into. Yeah,
I'm sure. I'm sure most of the Muni,
but really that like,
do they not realize that that actual
racism was condescending to is just,
it's, you know, yeah. Do you remember,
I think we discussed this once,
but I'd love to just dive
back into it for a second.
Like a moment in your formative years,
your younger years when
you finally were just like,
this is what it is and I'm just,
I'm just going to say what it is.
I can't think of a time like that.
I,
I know that had been many times where
I've said things and we've gotten,
gotten a hell for it.
I remember being in college,
we read Daniel Patrick Moynihan report
that I mentioned that to you called a
Negro family. That's national action,
a classical liberal, by the way,
Daniel Patrick and I got hammered by
the whites of my class for being, uh,
uh, uh, pro, uh, patriarchal. I
think half of the term that was used.
And I'm in the raising the inner city
and I saw a problem and I thought that
Daniel Patrick Patrick Moynihan was a,
was a canary in the coal mine and talked
about this problem. So I said, so,
and I got hammered. Yeah. But I
don't remember any particular moment.
I've always just been confident about
who I am and what I am. And, um,
my parents always told me that I could
be whatever I want it to be and my dad
was a republican and so I watched
all my dad walk into a voting booth.
This is during the primary season in,
in my neighborhood and because
there's nothing but Democrats there,
there must have been about 10 or 12
little booths where you stand in for the
Democrat one for Republicans for that
where guy that came there and it's my dad,
he's the only Republican
in my whole neighborhood.
And he would come up there and every
everybody courses see he's Republican
because he'd walk up there,
you didn't care.
And he knew that a lot of blacks felt
republicans were bad people and evil
people. He didn't care. My father
couldn't have cared less. And um,
yeah, it's just this, this thing
around race it, it's gross.
I hate the fact that I even where we have
you on that we ended up talking about
this. It is girls, especially when you,
when you consider America is the least
racist white majority society in the
country, the only one that's ever elected
a black president and reelected one. Um,
Orlando Patterson, the, um,
he's a left wing or a
sociologist at Harvard said
America has more opportunities
for blacks and any other
country in the entire world,
including all of those in Africa. Yeah.
Best Fared, best educated. Um, you know,
and here we are bitching and moaning
and whining about what happened. Uh, uh,
during slavery and Jim Crow. I mean,
honestly, in order to, to be successful,
this was a, this was a, um, an aid to
Bill Clinton. He said, you need to do,
do three things to escape poverty.
Graduate from high school.
Don't have a kid before you're 20 and
get married before you have a kid.
If you follow that formula, only seven
or 8% of people are poor. However,
if you don't follow that formula, the
majority of people are going to be poor.
That's it. Now, what does
it have to do with racism?
Would have to do with David Duke
explaining that to me. Yeah. Let,
let's talk about that part of it
though. So the, the, the David Duke's,
it's so silly to even have to bring
him up or, or just whatever the,
whatever the truly racist
part of the rite is.
And I do believe it does exist there.
There are racist, there are actual races.
There are, you know, some of
this, some of the all right crew,
whatever that [inaudible] on the and left.
Absolutely.
I just want to give it to the devil, his
due I on the right for a moment. However,
however, uh, uh, David Duke doesn't
have a TV show every Sunday on MSNBC.
The way I'll show up into us,
I'll sharpen falsely accused a white man
of raping to want Brawley referred to
mayor, uh, uh,
David Dinkens a first and only black
mayor of New York as an inward whore. Uh,
he was right in the thick
of the crown heights riot,
which was the most serious program
in the history of the of America.
He's on tape urging Jews,
depend their yama clothes and come
over my house and let's get it on.
He's on a surveillance tape with the FBI.
I discussing doing a cocaine deal.
He owes $5 million in taxes.
He's got a TV show on MSNBC
every Sunday interviewing a list.
Important people,
Scotty beam me up.
And so when I hear all this stuff about
the, the, the racism on, on, on the right,
and this guy has a show,
I mean, it's outrageous.
And Don Lemon recently referred to
Brock a to the Donald Trump quote as a
racist. Nothing happened. Glenn
Beck, who's not a news guy,
he's a commentator called Barack
Obama, a racist and a, uh,
group called color of change,
which is a,
a major Searles backed left wing
organization, put a petition.
The targeting has advertisers.
Nobody had a problem with Don
Lemon calling Trump a racist,
but calling Obama Racist,
oh my goodness.
Bring out the pitchforks is the problem
there that you don't want your side in
this case to start using the same tactics.
So it's almost,
it becomes like an uneven
battlefield, right? So like, um,
what's her name on Fox? Laura
Ingram says the thing about, uh,
David Hogg was it right?
And then, and then she gets
boycotted and Fox definitely,
at least for a couple of days,
was considering firing her. Him,
I'm told I'm pretty good account. Wow.
Uh, yeah. And, or at least, you know,
there was going to be some sort of
longer suspension or something and uh,
that the right doesn't do that. The
right just, if somebody on the left says,
I ain't crazy or, or just let's use the
case of the guy you're talking about,
so I'll sharpen, he's on Msnbc and
it's just like, yeah. All right.
Nobody's watching this nonsense. Let,
well, the double standards, we just, it's,
it's just, uh, it's in the
cake. A recent example of that,
um, is this staffer, apparently a
low level staffer in the White House,
which was discussing the fact that John
Mccain apparently going to vote against,
Gina has mold the nominee for the,
for the CIA.
And the staffers said something to the
effect of, that's okay, he's dying anyway.
Close quote. How that got out is beyond
me, but it gets out, her name gets out.
Uh, and now Donald Trump is being attacked
because he hasn't apologized to John
Mccain and John Mccain family for,
with this low level staffer
says when Obama was in office,
I think was 2014 a quotes senior Obama
official close quote was how the hill
described it,
referred to Benjamin Netanyahu,
the prime minister of Israel as chicken
bleep, except it wasn't bleep. Yeah.
And also called him a coward.
Nobody, nobody pressured the Obama,
no apologizing. And Obama didn't
apologize, John Kerry did, uh, to, to, uh,
not in Yahoo, but uh, but Trump won.
But the Obama was not pressured into,
into saying this. Now what's worse,
calling one of our closest allies,
chicken bleep or some low level staff
referring to a senator because of his vote
and it doesn't matter. He's going to,
he's dying anyway, which is worse.
And which one caused, no, the more
controversy, the one about Mccain did,
the one about, uh, Obama tree fell
in the forest, didn't make a sound.
So with all the understandable,
the stain that you have for
the mainstream media, and I,
and I'm with you on all of
that. And, and you know,
the things that I see people say about
you or just this group of people that I
know to be decent human beings.
Are you at all concerned that if the
mainstream media completely collapses,
which I would argue either has already
happened or is an inevitability,
at least at this point,
that what we're going to be left with
is such a siloing of opinion that we are
going to be completely unable to have
any sort of national conversation.
May look, maybe that gets
everything back to a local level,
which I would be okay with. But are you
concerned with that at all? I'm, I'm not.
Um, I'm not one of those who thinks things
are worse now than they've ever been.
I mean,
this is a country where we've,
we fought over a big issues for a long
time. Uh, the revolutionary war of course.
Uh, and then of course we had the war of
1812. We had the civil war, World War One,
World War II, Vietnam,
Korean War, w nine 11.
Uh, people hated Ronald Reagan. I
thought he was a, uh, George Bush. Uh,
uh, what was it? Bush lied. People died.
Uh, there's tension in this country.
There always has been a for
a very long period of time.
We get along better now than ever
before. We've, I said, man, I,
I don't think you can understate the
fact that we elected and reelected the
black president. Uh, in the 50s.
The polls show that the percentage of
white Americans who would be willing to
vote for a black person, no matter
how well to call it for qualified,
was in the single digits.
And now I think only three
or 4% of Republicans and
Democrats say that under no
circumstances would they vote for a
black person, for president. In fact,
the greater prejudice against the Mormon,
uh,
and it gets worn for a woman than it is
voting for a black person now. So, uh,
America is a very different
place than it used to be.
And for the left to act like it's not
insults the men and women who worked hard
to get us to where we are
right now. Yeah. Well,
just that lack of acknowledgement
of how things have moved forward.
When I did this University of
New Hampshire thing last week,
I said at the beginning of the speech, I
said, everyone in this room, I would say,
I would guess this without exception,
that everyone in this room has it
better than their grandparents had it.
And I didn't see anyone nodding.
Nobody, nobody said no, there's,
they're still yelling at me after about
all of this, this stuff. Meanwhile,
they're at an extremely good
school and all of those things,
but it's a lack of acknowledgement
of reality, right. I mean,
let me give you a sort of
a trivial example. Personal
example. I was in school, um,
uh,
in college in the late seventies,
and I met a woman, um,
later on in Cleveland,
I met a woman whose father
was a aeronautical engineer
and he was about 10 years
younger than my dad. And I said, she
first said he was an engineer and I said,
well, can I engineer? I thought she meant
like a trained engineer and she said,
aeronautical engineer. I said, your dad
is an aeronautical engineer. I have to,
where do you go to school?
When she told me he went to school with
a black school in the south and I said,
I would imagine they're no more than
five guys his age plus or minus 10 years
with a degree in aeronautical engineering.
And she went back home and ask her dad
and her dancing maybe five guides. He was,
she was, she had no idea how weird
this guy was. And so I met him,
I talked with him and I said, would
have, when you got out of school,
I couldn't get a job. I wrote to
everywhere, which wrote to Westinghouse.
I wrote to every major company
and nobody would hire me.
And I was going to get on a freight and
go to Mexico because I heard they were
hiring. And right before they're going
to get on the frightened, I had no money.
I got a phone call from the government
and began working for the government,
rest of his life engineer now,
um,
in the 70s,
I was in college and uh,
excuse me in law school and I had
a roommate who was an engineer,
a computer engineer,
and Dave,
the companies recruited
him like he was in, in c a
and he had another good friend too. Same
thing, both of them. One of them ended up,
um,
a long career at Procter and gamble and
made so much money that he dedicated a
wing to the, to the computer school at
Michigan. And the other one, my roommate,
William, is still with TRW.
Very good career there.
They were recruited like rock and my
girlfriend's father could not get a job as
an engineer, uh, when he got out of
school. That's a difference between,
and that was an, and I was in, in law
school in late seventies, at 40 years ago.
You're telling me now things are much,
much better than, than even then.
And then they were recruited like
rockstars, knock it off. Do your homework,
graduated from high school.
Don't have a kid before you're 20 years
old and get married first and you will
be just fine in America.
Yeah.
And it's so interesting how a healthy
society deals with its past injustices
because I use the examples of
going to Monte Cello, you know,
Thomas Jefferson's house
where you take that tour.
They are very honest about
his relationship to slavery
that he was having an
affair with at least one slave and
affairs isn't right. Kind word to say.
Uh, while, uh,
while at the same time writing the laws
that freed the slaves where I went to
George Washington's house and he didn't
free his half of the slaves until he
died. It was in his will, but Martha
still kept the other half. But they,
but they acknowledge all of that and
there's so many people that just want to
point at them and say they were racists
and this country was founded by them.
They knew it was a cancer and it was,
and that it was going to, um, uh,
at some point after the point where we're,
where something had to be done.
They knew it. Ben Franklin, his
last speech was a fiery speech, uh,
urging the abolition of slavery.
In fact,
he founded in a society for the
abolition of slavery. So the,
the founding fathers, uh, many of
them were conflicted. Uh, but, uh,
many of them were aware that
this is something that we
need to deal with energy.
Know that in the constitution there's a
specific date that says at this point,
and this, there'll be no more importation
of slaves and they goes 18, 24
and yet people want to want to kind
of sit in this and not let us escape.
And then, and then it leads to
identity politics on the left,
which then I think is the
reason that we now have a,
a version of identity politics on the
right. And then, and that were caught.
Well, 7 billion people, uh, are
in the world and I dare say it,
and most of them would trade places
with us if they could. Yeah. Uh,
and most Americans, many
Americans, unfortunately don't,
don't seem to appreciate
that. Yeah. All right.
So let's talk about California a little
bit in La in particular because as you
said, born and bred in
La. Um, south central,
if I'm not mistaken right now they call
it south la because south central has a
negative connotation. So they moved
it and now they call it [inaudible].
That's very fancy, very fancy. Um,
but we actually live about 10 minutes
away from me for another tell how old
somebody is in La, if they refer to the
area where I grew up in south central,
south north of 50 calls the south
central. Anybody south of 50 calls it,
I did not even know it was south la now,
but that's, I knew there was a west La,
I didn't even, I used to call
us. I knew there was east La,
south central became synonymous
with black la and that's racist.
So therefore they stopped doing it.
I think also real tourist
didn't like it either.
They didn't like the area of being
called south central because it meant the
property values might, uh, might
not be as high. Yeah. Well,
we also have an area here, Baldwin
hills that's known as the black right.
Beverly Hills. And actually when I
was going to buy a house when I was,
I ended up at this, I went to Baldwin
Hills. Beautiful area and it's gorgeous.
I didn't know,
I actually didn't know that it was
known as the Black Beverly Hills.
And obviously that wouldn't
have bothered me or anything.
But when I went to the house and I'm
looking at the house and it's actually
pretty nice and the prices pretty,
pretty decent relative to whatever,
cause there's some oil things
over there and whatever else. Um,
I remember the realtor was
like, and you, you know,
it's 90% black and 6% Hispanic
and 2% white or something.
And I was like, all right. All right.
All right. Yeah, it's okay. We're all,
we're all humans.
All right.
But I want to talk about La and California
in general because I do sense that
because progressive politics
have gone so bananas here.
And you referenced San Francisco earlier
and I was just there and our car got
broken into and they stole
my bag. And it, you know,
basically 10 o'clock at night in
front of a nice restaurant and the,
and I literally saw someone
shooting up and they were,
they were homeless tents
and all of this stuff.
I think that because progressive politics
have gone so overboard that there is a
little bit of a libertarian
streak started to take root here.
I took a deep breath in,
as I said,
I hope you're right because the
homelessness problem is massive. Uh,
our budgets are terrible.
The fastest growing item on the budget
is a unfunded pension liabilities from
all the, uh, generous packages
that we've given a garment workers.
Those workers are our young, many
of them, I think in California,
I read there about 10,000
former government workers,
they get pensions have $100,000 a year
or more for the rest of their lives,
which are adjusted for cost of living far
more generous than any pension you get
in the private sector. So when you
could get one in the first place.
So that's on automatic pilot and we're
driving away businesses with all the
taxes.
California has been rated the worst
state in which to do business for every
single year.
A magazine called CEO Magazine has
been in business a and small business.
People have also rated it as one of the
worst places in which to do business.
That's why we're losing
in a Digitas population.
People born and raised in California,
going to places like Texas and
Nevada and Florida. It's interesting.
I was in Denver last week and uh,
the Uber driver was showing me how
there's Denver just exploding right now.
They're just,
the whole area is exploding and all the
rural areas are just becoming bigger and
bigger and bigger and the
guy goes, well, you know,
we got lower taxes here in Colorado,
so all you rich California
people are coming here. So
we're, we're really, I mean,
people really need to understand that
people eventually decide to use the foot
vote and go, all right, I'm
sick of paying these taxes.
I'm going to go live in a mansion
where I can only live in a apartment.
A little go and you go online and see
it. There's a, there's a, there's a,
there's an online site that
shows where the money goes,
tax revenues and where and where it's
going. Where is it going? And it's going,
it's going to look to the so called
red states. States like Wyoming,
a state like that are, are, are,
are finding a blooming population
and states like Illinois, uh,
and California and Connecticut are losing
indigenous population to other states.
Yeah.
Because of the taxes in the regulations.
Do you think there's any chance
some of this could be reversed here?
You've been here for a long,
they had longer.
I've only been here for five
years and I'm slightly hopeful.
Here's the problem with California. The
demographics are not in our favor. Uh,
in 19, uh, I think it was 80, 1994,
I think it was prompted,
you want 87 passed.
Talk about a quote, harsh, uh,
anti illegal immigration law.
When you tell me what 87 for bad
illegals using education funds,
uh, did not allow, uh,
illegal aliens to use any medical
funds except for emergency. So no,
no education, no healthcare, no nothing.
Illegal aliens. It passed among whites.
It passed among blacks, it passed
among Hispanics, uh, excuse me,
pass them on Asians. It did not pass
a course about Hispanics at the time.
The Hispanic vote in California with
maybe 20, 10%. Now it's about 25%.
And it's, and it's rising.
And Hispanics believe,
especially those from Mexico,
Republicans are racist and they only
care about the rich la times did a study
and asked them questions like that.
And those are the two responses
that were the most frequent.
Republicans are racist,
only care about the rich,
selfish and only care about the rich.
Uh,
and they don't come from a libertarian
point of view at a federalist point of
view. They don't know from, uh, from
Thomas Jefferson, from Article One,
section eight of the constitution,
which limits the federal
government to a handful of things,
leaving everything else to the
states and the individuals,
they don't know from that.
So the point is, we got our
work cut out for us. Listen,
we could do this forever.
That was a quick freaking hour.
And I know you've got a hard out cause
you got it. You got it. Yeah. Yeah,
I have a radio show to do right now.
Got a radio show to do. Um, all right,
we're going to do the heavier fans.
Follow me on Twitter at Larry
elder at Larry elder. I'm a pro.
It's all right there.
Follow him on Twitter and I've got
a book called the elders statement.
Elder statement.com. Yeah. What are
you going to bring the mustache back?
Every time I Google image search you and
there's, I'm gonna rock the flowback.
You see my picture?
That picture?
I retweeted that picture because
you add I wasn't, that was like, uh,
well what happened is this troll said,
you think your wife,
you've always wanted to be white.
You probably always want to be white.
And so I said, really? And I put that
picture of that one out today. I want to,
I want to share it. So I will be looking
at saying, all right, man, listen,
it's a pleasure. There is a place, I
don't want to mention it on air. Uh,
but there is a new restaurant
right in between our houses.
Like right in between that is
freaking awesome. Right around here.
I'm taking it out. Say the
word for dinner. You and your
girlfriend, you've got it.
It's been a pleasure, my
friend. I'm sorry. We have
to do this real quick. We're,
we're to, we'll do this again.
All right. Power to the people.
Death to the fascist pig. I can't do
better than that. And communication.